here now with reaction someone who was
also targeted by members of her own
party former democratic presidential
candidate congresswoman tulsi gabbard
congresswoman welcome back
when you see that video
and you know that joe biden is trying to
to bring
some
some basic common sense back to the
party
what's your reaction
uh sean what bothered me most when i saw
that video was really the exaggeration
and the dishonesty where you have people
there who are essentially trying to
create a viral moment and a headline and
yelling out joe manchin's trying to run
us over
this is just the latest example of a
disturbing larger pattern of dishonesty
and disrespect for the american people
where they think that we're just stupid
we saw this in the excuses that were
laid out when mcauliffe lost in virginia
they said oh well you know yunkan won
because he uh sounded he sounded his dog
whistle and then all the dogs came out
and and voted and and that's why he won
and it and it reveals really what they
think about us that we're stupid that
we're dogs that we don't have
intelligence or free will to make our
own decisions for ourselves
and therefore we should just trust
them in their arrogant attitude that
they and the big government they know
what's best for us and they'll they'll
make the best decisions for us you know
use the analogy um
i was the emcee the night newt gingrich
became speaker in 1994
and it was a wake-up call
remember republicans have been out of
power in the house of representatives
for 40 years
and it became a wake-up call for bill
clinton and that's when he changed gears
and the era of big government is over
the end of welfare as we know it
this modern democratic socialist party i
do not see has any capacity to
change course or adjust
what we've seen since tuesday is full
steam ahead on socialism do you see the
same thing
what i see is this continued disrespect
of the american people unless we look at
the underlying problem here is that we
don't have leaders who actually respect
the american people who actually respect
us enough to listen to listen to what
parents are concerned about
uh you know their children and their
education to listen to the american
people who are sick and tired of the
power elite trying to tear us apart
based on the color of our skin
they don't respect us enough to listen
so how can we ever expect them to
actually act in our best interests
rather than the interests of themselves
their power or the power of the elite
you know i'm watching joe manchin and
natural gas and coal these are huge
industries in his state
these policies will directly and
negatively impact the people of west
virginia so he's standing up for the
people that put him in office
as as you look at this emerging party
led by the squad led by new green deal
socialism
do you even consider yourself a democrat
anymore
i i'm less concerned about party
politics yes i'm a democrat but i'm less
concerned about party politics than i am
concerned about the future of our
country given the kind of leadership
that we are seeing this kind of
self-serving leadership that plunges
forward you just played a few different
clips that really again reveal the
arrogance of of this leadership that
plunges forward without any regard for
the costs and consequences on the
american people in the short term or the
long term the cost and consequences on
our freedoms on on
the undermining of our constitutional
rights there are deeper issues here that
really need to be brought to the
forefront that most in the media are not
even talking about you know i there was
a period in my life congresswoman where
i had to struggle for a lot of years to
pay rent i know what it's like the high
cost of gasoline
totally preventable we were energy
independent why would we ever give that
up what happened at the border totally
preventable we had a policy that was
working afghanistan another example we
could have withdrawn when we had full
control of kabul and all the surrounding
areas we had months to do it they didn't
do it uh and then then you look at
inflation then you look at energy prices
and you put all of this together who's
getting hurt here the the the
people that make this country great the
working men and women of america the
people that really really you know the
poor the middle class
you know paid about 50 more a gallon i
can afford it but a lot of people can't
and there seems to be a disconnect in
terms of caring about those people
and that's really what's at the heart of
the frustration that people across the
country are feeling right now is that
they are not
being heard that they are not being seen
that seeing that their challenges uh
really are not being addressed by those
in power you you listed a number of
different challenges and
our our representatives in government
they'll have different ideas on how to
address those things but when you look
at issues related to open borders and
immigration when you look at issues
related to our national security when
you look at issues related to energy
independence
we can have different ideas on how to
accomplish those things but those things
are concerns that are central to all of
us regardless of political parties so if
we treat each other with respect as
children of god and come together to say
hey we need to work together for the
good of the country then we can have
that real dialogue that will allow us to
move forward and make progress to solve
these problems boy i'll give a big amen
to that well very well said
congresswoman we appreciate you always
coming on the program thank you tulsi
gabbard